thank you for coming to the talk today
yeah we can pitch Park as well we kind
of took over the room this morning just
quickly to do some setup so a lot of
what we're going to do this morning will
be in a notebook so it's great if you
have it working you have two options
here first one is you go to my github
and you clone that and you should have
the data I wrote some functions in the
helpers that why because I don't want to
have like a lot of messy stuff in a
notebook and you've got all the setup
instructions here so that's the first
option if you can't be bothered
setting up setting it up locally I've
tried to do a google collab as well so
basically you click on this thing yeah
you copy paste this yo and that should
give you that so that gives you access
to a notebook remotely that you can open
in playground mode and once you do that
they will ask you to to log in with your
Google account so if you have a Google
account and then you can actually
execute the cells like you would do in a
normal notebook so I'm putting the URL
again maybe I give you five minutes so
everyone is set up with that to either
github or collab I have a short URL as
well for github if you don't want to tap
that
and yeah if you I'm good yeah
putting that on the site mmm it's not
what I want to zoom you know what okay
go get them just want sure that as well
cool yeah so if you're on collab you can
run the first cell to start with it's
just to to set up everything so I gotta
install a few libraries and download
some some data so if you just run this
one then you're good to go and we can
move on
Jenny little bit more time who who has
it working already with just one person
okay cool so two more minutes maybe
also I'd like to live dangerously so I
actually pushed to the github and have a
go just change the version of shop
because they've got I've been using an
older version and not if change the API
so hopefully everything is going to work
but who knows right so well at least you
have there the URLs I'm just gonna get
started now how do I put that back yeah
cool
great so so yeah today we're gonna talk
about interpretability that's gonna be
really fairly introductory I just want
to present a few libraries that you can
use to interoperate in your models so
it's also going to be fairly applied
we'll start with just a really quick
introduction why why it's useful and
then present those three libraries here
so the first one is Eli five that allows
you to interpret white box models so
models are not too complex and there was
a Lyman chapter actually allowing you to
generate explanations of more complex
models so why do we need and why do we
care about interpreting our models so
let's say you've done all the work for
data scientists you've clean for
pre-processed messy data so as we've
said some others have said yesterday
it's most of the job for data centers
cleaning messy data then you've
engineered really fancy new features
you're quite proud of them you selected
the best models you've tuned it
you've tuned that you've trained that
you've got great performance you're
really happy with what you've done but
then your boss comes to you and it's
asking well can you explain how your
model works and why why does it take
those decisions and that's something
that's more and more happening machine
learning is used in more and more
industries everyone wants to be on board
start building fancy models
you'll see them in all industries
insurance banks even the police is
looking at try to predict if someone is
gonna commit a crime in advance you
don't want your model to be a black box
in those in those situations you don't
want it to pick some like for example
having gender bias or bias towards some
minorities or things like that he had in
another example social media I think
it's it it might seem less important
than the three above it but I think it's
super important if the example I wanted
to bring here is say you have company
doing online like a casino poker or
whatever and they want to target ads on
social media if you have a model that is
telling them well the best person to
recommend going on your website to do
gambling is people that have gambling
addictions then it can be really big a
really big issue so that can have a
really bad impact as well if you don't
have any control on what your model does
and what it picks up on so black box
models it's not really an option in many
industries so I want to just go through
two examples the first one is really bad
the second one is just inconvenient so
the first one I have a quote from get
Union here as well so models are
opinions embedded in mathematics so
that's the whole garbage in garbage out
thing if your data has bias in it your
model is just gonna learn this bias and
then you you you can't say that your
model is fair because it has just
learned whatever you had in your data so
an example here and I think that's a
real example she gives in her book that
say you have your work at a big company
you want to predict performance of your
employees as data variable you have past
performance we've used for individual
employees for the last ten years but
what if you company tends to promote
men more than women then those
performance reviews will have will be
more positive for men than women and
your model is just going to learn that
is just going to do if the person if the
employee is a man then they more
performance and that you will just embed
that bias into into your model and then
when you're you're using it you're just
gonna enforce that so that's that's
something really bad and that's
something you need to spot early before
deploying your model or you can just
amber that you know all your well
whatever you're doing with your model
later another example it's just
sometimes you you've been building a
model that is actually not doing at all
what you expected to do and that's an
example that they that they quote in the
in the paper why should I trust you so
that's the the paper that came when when
they release the library lime that we're
going to talk about later so they wanted
to classify images some of words some of
huskies and they ended up having good
accuracy but what I figured out when
they when I started using lime and
that's something we're going to show
later is that the model wasn't actually
looking at at the dog or at the wolf
where he was looking at the background
and just saying if there is no just
classify it as a wolf if there is not
snow classified as a husky so what
you've done you thought you had a nice
classifier wolf versus dog but actually
you just built a snow detector so that's
that's something again that you you
wanna spot and for that you need to be
able to like analyze your model and see
what what it's what features it picks
and everything so that's why we're going
to do today now there are different
different types of models some of them
are actually really easy to interpret so
that's the case of linear model for
example logistic regression here you
have weights associated to each feature
you know the exact contribution of each
of the features you know if it's
negative or positive so I give a really
basic example here when you're
increasing X 1 by 1 unit you know that
your Y width will increase by 3 units
you can explain exactly what your model
does in height X its decision a single
decision tree is really easy to
interpret as well
you've got the whole decision path so
when you're making a new production for
example here that's from the Titanic
that I said I think so you're looking
first is is it a male well it's a male
here you're you in trouble
and you're much more likely to die so
that's again you can explain exactly how
the decision was made now you have other
models that a little bit harder to
interpret and that's a great example is
ensamble models so they distill I mean
random fries for example are great and
boosting they will still rely on entrees
so you can still get the feature
importance but first thing the future
importance is calculated differently in
in different libraries that you'll be
using in random forest it will aggregate
it will average all the future
importance from all the trees that you
have in your model for boosting is more
tricky every library will have a
different definition of how when you
have feature importance from all your
trees how do I get that so you can't
always reach rust it and you don't have
a unified way to know what what's the
important feature and also something
that doesn't give you it's telling you
how well you know that the feature is
important but you don't know how if it's
positively affecting your decision or
negatively so that's something that
you'd like to know as well and then you
have another category of modal dies
completely a black box that you can't
really do much with it and those ones
probably the hardest so then there is a
fair question that you can ask does it
mean that we we have to use only simple
model well that could be a solution as
probably the best solution if you using
and that's
I think what Hugo was saying yesterday
that a lot of the data sent is he
interviewed is in his podcast was saying
that logistic regression is really
underrated like if you want to interpret
interpretable model the best ways to use
a really simple model that you can
interpret easily but that's not what I'm
here to talk about some hip talk about
the second option what if you still want
to use fancy models that that are more
performance but still be able to
interpret them so there you have a set
of techniques and that's what we're
going to talk about right now so just to
start with Eli five so I don't know if
you familiar with the Eli five subreddit
but it's explained like I'm five so it's
a he created a library that is just
looking at are the different internals
of scikit-learn models so it works
mostly for for simple models so the the
first category that was showing their
logistic regression single decision tree
and it's explaining really simply what
what is important by how much so the
linking you weights to features and
think and things like that so we'll show
that in a notebook in a second it
provides global interpretation so it
tells you how overall your model works
but it can also be used to provide a
local explanation so for a given
prediction that your model has made how
did it take its decision just quickly on
on the API so you've got a few and here
we'll see only two of the methods in in
Eli five the first one is sure wait so
it's to have the global interpretation
of the model and then you can explain a
single observation with show prediction
so let's go to the notebook do you all
have that working now at least we scroll
up if not locally yeah
who still need more time or set up or
has issues or whatever
cool great that's amazing yeah yeah the
yeah I can put it back where is it
disappeared this one yeah I'm just gonna
copy it in that book second start
working as well oh yeah also something
I've got a comment here I'm gonna use
features from pythons 2.3.6 and some new
classes that were introduced in
scikit-learn point 20 so that's the
latest version so if you're using older
versions of of scikit-learn just make
sure you upgrade before otherwise you
won't be able to run it right so I'm
importing a bunch of things here just
quickly - well Pender's obviously then a
few pre-processing classes from from
scikit-learn so one horton coder because
they've got categorical values the
column transformer so that's the one I
was talking about that's from the new
version of circular I don't know who he
has used the column transformer before
no one oh yeah great do you like it yeah
it makes it makes the pipeline like much
much cleaner and then a pipeline and a
few a few classes to compute accuracy
specification reporting train test split
and then here I'm gonna end up with four
for the whole workshop we're going to
focus on four models of increasing
increasingly complex so we'll start with
logistic regression which should be
really easy to explain decision if you
classify a little bit harder random
forest classifier a little bit harder
but still possible and then their
gradient boosting where different trees
don't carry much much meaning so it's
harder to interpret so let's load all
that just a quick introduction of what's
what's data said so I just find it on
you see I website that you can access it
here it's basically related to direct
marketing campaigns a Portuguese bank
just contacted some of the clients in
the trying they try to have them
subscribe to some term deposit so that's
why we're going to predict whether the
client subscribe to it or not
and that's gonna be the variable Y so
let's load that here we noticed that
there is imbalance of of the places so
only a few amount of people actually
subscribe to to the Atem deposit after
the marketing campaign so we'll need to
keep that in mind thankfully all the
models were using a easily support class
imbalance and we can add more weight on
the on the monomeric class so we're
going to build x and y so y here which
is mapping no to zero yes one so every
time is year one that means the person
subscribed and yeah we ready here a few
introduction on what what the features
are so we've got the age of the of the
client we've got their job Meital status
education bunch of things we've got a
month when the campaign happened the day
of the week all sort of things we've got
some weird features that i investigated
a little bit it seems to be related to
to the state of of the bank so i don't
know why they included for example the
number the number of employees in in the
bank when they contacted the clients but
that's there and spoiler alert it's
actually one of the main features and
we'll talk a little bit by why later now
yeah there's just quick notes duration
here it's a big data leakage that's the
duration of the last call so that's when
they were supposed to actually subscribe
to the
to the the plan so here we're gonna get
rid of it because that if if that last
call to subscribe to the plan is has a
duration of zero that means they didn't
subscribe to the plan if the duration
positive that means they might have
subscribed so we're just getting rid of
it and yeah we will go from there then a
few values here categorical so what I'm
doing is just finding a list of
numerical features categorical features
and I'm going to process them
differently where is the column
transformer so here if you haven't used
the current transformer before what
you've got to do is just define a
transformation that you want to do on
each each group of features that you
have so here I'm saying that for my
numerical numerical features
I'm just keeping them like they are I
don't modify them whatsoever just keep
them as they were initially but for my
categorical features I'm going to apply
the one hot encoder transformation on it
so that's my preprocessor object that I
can then later on use in in a cyclotron
pipeline has everyone used scikit-learn
pipeline yeah yeah cool so we're going
to do that now we have our preprocessor
we can define our for model so the first
model logistic regression is just my
preprocessor and the largest logistic
regression algorithm here you see I've
defined the class way that's being
balanced I'm doing the same thing for
decision tree so I have got my decision
tree model that has a preprocessor
decision tree algorithm same thing class
weight balance random forest and then
the extra boost mobile XE boost notice
that it's not actually from scikit-learn
but it's it comes with the say
scikit-learn api so i can just use it in
my pipeline as any other model right so
are we ready to go
obviously we split the data into tray
and test so we can actually check the
accuracy of a file model here unit is
the the argument stratify just so we
make sure that the distribution of Y's
is the same in the training set and
testing set all right so we're good to
go
so now we look at Eli 5 so with Eli
fight we only look at the white box
models here so the logistic regression
and the decision tree we are not going
to use it for the more complex models
they actually have functions that should
give you interpolation of them but will
prefer Lyman sharp for that right so
logistic regression files and that's
where it might take a while I just I
just wanted to do the whole the whole
process here live but that means I'm
doing a grid search CV live which might
take a while here it was really quick so
I've got my best parameters best core
I'm overriding the the parameters of my
model to be the best diameters and here
I can verify that all worked well so
here my best
see after grid search was one point five
if I just check it here this should be a
one point five somewhere yeah here it is
so I've probably overwritten into my
pipeline the value of C so now I can fit
it on my training set and I'm good to go
well the first thing you do then you've
got your model that has been tuned
you can now test how accurate it is on
the testing set so here 83% let's look
at the actual classification report yeah
and as usual we we actually not as good
as the accuracy score would be you as
you would think looking at the accuracy
score only because the class 1 which is
the minority class you've got a much
lower recall and precision so
that's something that you can do first
but then I mean here there's a much more
we can do we will look at Eli 5 to
interpret your model so we know the
overall accuracy we know today is good
enough to predict the the majority class
0 but to predict the the minority class
1 it's not that good that's the first
thing you know by looking at the
classification report the second thing
is the window we want to know how
different features are picked in our
model so Eli 5 allows us to do that
we're just importing it here and we use
the show wait the show wait method that
will just look at the wait it's it's not
doing anything fancy here and just
looking at the weight of your logistic
regression and showing it with nice
colors it's nothing nothing crazy I'm
passing my model so I need to take it
into into my pipeline because it needs
to get the logistic regression object so
that's why I'm using this name step
model here and you can see my features
and the word associated to it here it's
not amazing because the the features are
just numbers right so will we want to
pass the name of the the names of the
features here so there is a little bit
of gymnastic to do because the features
have been generated through after one
hot encoding so I need to actually get
the not the original names of the
features but first one hot including
some I'm 12 what am I good with time
yeah so probably gonna go really quickly
with that because the code is not that
important but I'm basically getting my
preprocessor then from the preprocessor
I can get my free process or the
preprocessor says the category called
features which is the one hot encoder
and from the one hot and cholera can get
the list of one hot encoded categories
and if we just look into this subject
it's basically telling me for each
feature for which I've built one Hut one
hut and create new features all the
possible options so here that's the
first ones the job for example so I've
got the list of all possible jobs so
once I have that it's fairly easy to do
build a list of features I just need to
flatten it on here you see that I'm
using a F string okay happy with that
and if I look at that that's basically
the object I've built all right so
that's that's the list
there's the flattened list of all all my
features passed when Horton coded and
encoding with first first element is
that the original feature that was there
for example the job and then the value
it took right so that that should map
exactly with all the other the dummies
I've created then I just add that up to
my numerical features and that's the
list of all my features in the data set
so I can check that here but if I if I
just for sanity check if I just build a
new data frame that has the data
post-processing and those columns there
I see that I have the right name some
like I can trust this little gymnastic
right cool so now that we have the name
of all the all the features we are able
to make alive a little bit better and
see what what features it's actually
picking and now it seems to that the
most important feature for that logistic
regression is whether the campaign
happened in March which might be where I
I don't know that's that's the that's
the first thing you can do once
have this disinformation you're able to
talk to whoever was in charge of the
marketing campaign ask was there
something you did differently in March
to be able to communicate this
disinformation better and that's what
Eli five in all the libraries we are
doing today is supposed to do help with
this it won't give you the answers to
all the questions it will just give you
a way to communicate that and discuss
with whoever knows more than you in in
the domain or if you know a lot in the
domain you can answer this question to
yourself
so here it's telling you it's picking
principally whether or not the month was
was much great so now we we can use the
second function that we saw from Eli
five which is show observation so it
will it can explain a single a single
prediction so here let's pick this this
person so 27 years old
we don't know their job we know that the
same your the difficult university
degree so quite a bit of information and
that person happened to subscribe to our
marketing campaign so now we'll use Eli
five to see how our logistic regression
decided whether or not that person
subscribed so we just run this and he
have done exactly the same thing of pass
to have used to show prediction method
but I've passed my model I've passed the
data set I need to transform it with the
preprocessor first just to make sure it
has access to the dummy variables I have
done and then the list of all my
features so if I do that here I see what
we looked at like that what it looked at
so actually predicted that this clients
subscribed to the term deposit with a
probability of 0.9 T 6% of 96% and it
principally looked at this variable
which only to look it up here comes
price consumer price index and actually
that's an interesting one because that's
one of those features that I find way it
that are not actually linked to the
clients but that are linked to the
company so here that's the first thing
you can say it's trying to use as a
proxy whatever whatever your company was
up to at that time right so here you've
got that that's monthly indicator that
they compute at the bank and that's what
it's using to make their prediction
whether or not someone will subscribe so
it's actually not even looking at what
what the client has characteristics but
only saying that this index here has
these values that used as a proxy to
know where like around what time you did
the marketing campaign and that's what
how it makes its pretty if a prediction
so by using that you can already tell
that your model is probably not that
great because it's it's not really good
at predicting based on the attributes of
the person it's good at predicting based
on what what what marketing campaign it
was or something like that and also like
it's it's got a really big negative
weight on the number of employees which
same thing is just an indicator related
to the bank at that time right so we can
use Eli five-four decision trees as well
so we'll do it right now I've got a chin
my model first I'm going to do the same
steps as I did before yeah
this one yeah so we've seen how big the
Tigers have we see near the value of
this feature so there yeah that's a good
question so here you've got the
coefficients so the coefficients are in
your global explanation of the model so
when you using show weights that's what
sure it's telling you when you're
checking the local explanation so for
specific prediction what it's doing is
just multiplying whatever value that
that observation has with the weights so
here what you see the number here it's
it's really big because the the value
for that specific prediction happened to
be that and it's multiplied by whatever
weights your logistic regression has and
same thing for the number of employees
here yeah do you have the weights as
well yeah there might be a wing so I
don't know just documentation right so
we can do the same thing for a decision
tree so I know I'm doing the grid search
again oh I can kill it perfect because
I've done it already
so I know my best parameters setting
that again that's getting a little bit
boring and I get the accuracy scores a
little bit better than before I think
still get the same classification
reports we still don't have a great
model but that does the job and here I
can do the same thing so I can use Eli
five so and that's one of the advantages
of Eli five is that because you you
could just tell me now that oh well
getting the weights for my logistic
regression I can do it by just doing
that weight with my logistic regression
and you could do the future importance
from the tree as well what's your life I
have provides you well it's got nice
colors it's the first time but it also
provides you a unified API to do that
all right so whether you have a logistic
regression decision tree or other models
you'll be able to use these show weights
so you can compare models really easy
because you've got a proper API to do
that so let's look at the decision tree
here same thing it's picking on the
number of number of employees so even
the decision tree is pretty bad model as
well and here it shows the the decision
tree if you want to look into more
detail I've got no idea how well I'm
doing which time is it finish at midday
yeah quite a pass okay cool plenty of
time right and you can also use the the
local interpreter to see for specific
observations so here we're going to look
at the same the same observation you see
that it will always have the bias versus
just where it starts at the top of the
tree it already has an assumption of
like a the probability so here we start
with like point five chance of being
class one and then we check the impact
of each feature each feature from there
so you you you will always have the bias
first and then you look at the features
after that so the most important again
for even for this specific prediction
was the number of employees so model
isn't great yeah that's all for alive do
you guys have any questions for Eli five
maybe it's good to do it now before we
start using other libraries no questions
great so let's go back to the slides and
talk about lime okay
right so lime so here we've used Eli 5
to interpret simple models and that
gives you that unified API to show you
what what features are important and
also to do local interpretation of your
models what if your model is more
complicated so that's the problem that
lime is trying to solve so there it is
paper in 2016
why should I trust you there's
explaining their approach to that and
some where explain how it works in a
second just two things to keep in mind
it's local so it doesn't do a global
interpretation of your model you can't
use that to know how your model works
globally but only you can see how it it
made its decision for specific
observation it's also model agnostic so
you can use it on any any model of
whatever complexity you want so you can
use it on on simple models you've seen
but also on more complex models that we
will do later so it does is a given a
model and given a specific observation
so here we have patient for example with
some symptoms you explained I will tell
you what symptoms your model picked in
the in the data and that's something
again that you can then communicate to
the domain expert so here the doctor
said but empowers you understanding
better you model them to a quiz with the
people that know the field so how does
it work so that's a drawing that they
have in that paper that's good that
gives a good intuition of how lime works
but it's not exactly how its implemented
so we'll just to explain this one here
you have a really complex model that
it's not linear at all so that's the
that's what you see in the background so
you have two classes the blue and the
orange or pink
and you build a model that is really not
linear that is telling you whether
something belongs to the class blue or
the class pink so what lime does it's
trying to forgive an observation so here
we want to say where wherever the cross
is here we want to generate an
explanation of this of this decision so
what lime will do is trying to
approximate your model with a linear
model in this area and then use the
weights of the linear model as
interpretation as we've done before for
with Eli 5 for example so the way does
that is by sampling some some data
randomly around your around your
observation so you say explain this red
cross here it will generate some some
data by sampling from the distribution
of the original data and then it will
fit a linear regression in in the
locality here and use the weights of
that linear regression as a in
explanation so it's that's the intuition
it's actually not exactly how it works
because things aren't binary they are
probabilistic so and it's much harder to
explain in two dimensions moving to one
dimension here say you have a model that
wants to let that predict whether or not
someone is likely to have a cancer based
on some features here I'll just have a
jazz figure so say you have you have one
one patient that is 20 years old and
your model predicted some probability
here and you want to explain that so
what lime will do is first sampling from
the from the distribution and predict
all all those values so here it's
sampled a lot of a lot of data around
that 20 years old spots and it uses your
model to predict the probability based
on that and once it's done that it's
able to fit
linear regression so here we're not in
the binary case anymore we we have
probabilities and we fit a linear
regression in that so here once it's
done that it can tell that around 20
years old adding one year doesn't seem
to have much impact on the probability
whereas say if you have another patient
that is older you have the probability
here
you're sampling from from the
distribution generating some
probabilities you fit your linear model
in here by looking at the other weights
associated to you Nene regression you
can tell that around this age the age
actually has more importance and the
weight associated to to that feature age
is much much bigger so that's how you
would would be able to generate
observations do to generate explanations
so you need to pass your your data to
the Lyme explainer yeah so for for
numerical values is just getting the
distribution for categorical values it's
looking at the frequency and so it's
picking from there right so you so I
explained you choose an observation you
create a new data set around that you
calculate the distance between the
points so that's something I didn't
mention here because it was hard to
visualize but it's assigning different
weights on the on the points that you
are that you're generating just to know
how similar they are to your original to
original point that you want to explain
so you want you don't want a point that
is quite far off to be weighted the same
as things that are really similar to to
your your point that you wanna explain
and then you use your model to predict
classes here also something that I
omitted lime is one of the parameters
that you pass through lime is the number
of features you want to use for your
explanation so here we only have one
feature but if you have multiple
dimensions you can say
generate an explanation with three
features only or four features and then
it fits a linear model and it gives you
the explanation based on the on the
weights if can work with images as well
and that's a really cool thing that we
might do if we have time at the end of
this of the network but given a an image
it can also tell you which part of the
image it used to predict so here it
predicted frog with probability of point
54 and it tells you that the main thing
it looked at to say that it's a frog is
the head here it also predicted I could
be both with 0.07 probability and it
looked at the eyes and the fingers of
the Frog it also predicted other classes
and it explained it shows you in the in
the image what weight so that can be a
really nice way to spot if your model is
actually doing the right thing and
that's how they did the first example
that I showed at the beginning right
some some drawbacks before we we go to
the network so it can be unstable
because it depends on the on the first
random sampling that you're doing
whatever model you're gonna build an
explanation that you're gonna show the
appends on that initial sampling it's
also fitting a linear model so if your
model isn't locally approximable can be
locally approximated by a linear model
so if your model is really nonlinear
then your u linear linear regression fit
it's not going to be good so your
explanation won't be good either lime
gives you access to the R square so you
can actually see if your if your linear
regression locally was good or not and
it can be fairly slow for images in
particular because it needs to generate
this data set so for images it's even
how it needs to generate image tons of
images from scratch before generating an
explanation they they have implemented
values explainers so you can
work with tabular data and that's where
we're going to do keeping the same
example but you can use it for time
series for images and for textures also
if you're working with those type of
data encourage you to to take a look at
that just a prequel and the API so
you're generating first an explainer
that that's why we learned the
underlying distribution and I will know
how to generate a data set and
everything once you have you explained
you can call the method explained
instance on it so passing given a given
observation and your new prediction
function from your model try to explain
how your model works by fitting the
linear regression and then you have once
you've generated an explanation you can
visualize it in different ways so let's
do that right so here we want to make it
a little bit more complicated so we're
going to use to fit a random forest and
actually boost model first and try to
interpret those so again I was a bit
ambitious and try to do great search
live so it's taking a while probably
it's faster if you guys are using collab
it's actually probably faster than my
laptop maybe because Google Cloud great
so accuracy a little bit better than
before
classification report here just wanted
to prove that I wasn't lying and Eli
five can actually work with with and
symbol models so here with my random
forest yeah it's it's interesting it
gives you pretty much the same results
as before
it adds the the standard deviation
because you've got multiple trees in
your ensemble now so you can know how
how confident all your trees are in
picking this feature as more important
than the others and let's do the same
for gradient boosting
please cool
accuracy whoo really good about here
my recoil is really bad I'm having a
really bad coverage of the classroom
anyway that's fine so let's import from
lime the tabular explainer so that's the
domain when we were going to use here
for tabular data your we need to create
that explainer that I was talking about
it's actually more complicated than just
passing the data set because we're doing
we're working with scatter you call
variables so it has the whole one-hot
encoding issue the problem is that the
explainer from lime needs the
categorical data not to be dummies and
also not to be strings either so they
need to be integer labels but still with
the original features so that means that
we've got to do a little bit of
gymnastics again to to get the data set
in the right format but still be able to
use our model so probably gonna skip the
details of that you have the code
available on how I managed to you like
put things together so it it's in the
right format for lime but one thing that
we need to do first is provide the list
of all categorical values technical
features and their possible outcome so
lime can can learn from that so I'm
generating it with this little code
snippet here and what I'm doing is just
basically saying that feature in the x1
which is the job has all those possible
values feature index to all those
possible values and I will need to pass
that to tool I'm here I didn't even want
to put that function in a notebook so I
to help us file and what's doing it's
just in something super basic it's just
taking your data set and it's looking at
all the catechol values in the data set
and converting the strings to integer
labels so I didn't want to have it here
to confuse people so if you want you can
see on my github it's right here
but yeah so I'm gonna import that and we
can see their work so if I give extra
into it with the list of categorical
names it's properly so if I check
extreme first so X train is in the form
in the right format for my model so
meeting like the original data set and
then when I use the convert to lime
format
it's just applying that transformation
to change get Oracle values into integer
labels so once I have all that I'm able
to create a lime explainer so I need to
pass all those things to the first one
my data said that I've converted to to
the line format I need to specify them
working with classification I need to
give a list of all my features so it's
able to provide me with a nice
explanation that tells me the name of
the feature I'm not just the index I
need to pass the name of the catechol
values so it knows which one to treat as
categorical and then as as I was saying
earlier it will need to not it it will
need to look at the frequency when it's
trying to sample from the distribution
and that kateri called names dictionary
that I've created above saying all the
possible values so that's little bit of
wiring here I think is not worth
explaining that more you probably need
to google it if you want to use it for
the first time anyway so no point
spending too much time on that and once
I have my explainer I'm ready to explain
stuff amazing so let's speak an
observation again define I equal to so
that's
one of the clients 35 years old
technician single professional cause
they contacted them with telephone great
good stuff
now I can see how all my models
predicted generated prediction for that
that specific client so the true label
was the earth that person didn't
subscribe to term deposit the logistic
regression here predicted class 0 with
71% decision tree with 75% when a first
80% and actually boost 92 percent so
actually here my exhibition aims to be
the most confident in predicting that
this person won't once subscribe so all
right
since fine now again need to convert
that to line format so that's been
annoying but fortunately I have a fancy
function to do that so let's do that and
now we ready to generate explanation
well actually not really there is
something else because here if you go
back to where I presented the API to
generate an explanation object we need
to pass an observation we have that well
we need to have an explainer first we
have that we need to pass an observation
we have that but we don't have the
product function so if your model will
be really basic the predict function
would be just the dot product from
whatever model you've built but here our
model has one heart and coded features
so our our predict functions need to be
able to work with the line format so it
needs to when lime is going to join to
use our model to generate predictions
probabilities it needs to be able to
pass that that data set in the weird
format with the integer labels and
generate probabilities with our model so
that means we need to overwrite that a
little bit so I've created another
function here that is just taking
whatever data lime wants to use I'm
having this invert parameter here so
that we'll just convert it back to the
right format
for my model and then I'm calling my
model right so it's just a wrapper I
have done so that I can pass from the
line format back to the original format
and call my my predict proper so once I
have that I'm able to create predict
proper functions for all my models so I
have my logistic regression decision
tree random for us extra boost so all
those functions here I've just F
creative is partial are able to predict
probabilities using data from within the
line format so I can pass those two to
line right so once I've done all this
every wiring I'm able to explain an
instance so I see my observation here
I'm going to start with my logistic
regression and I'm saying generate an
explanation with five features only
right so I do that it's done it was
really quick and I'm able to actually
visualize it
so I can call show in that book on my
explanation they have different methods
that allow you to do it more program it
programmatically so if you if you want
if you have a script or something you
can generate HTML version or whatever
but here we in a network so we're
showing in that book and that's how this
how it looks like so it says here I've
got the the outcome of the prediction so
it predicted 71% to class zero so the
person doesn't subscribe and the
remaining 29% for the class 1 and here
it explains what what it looked like
looked at so I've got class 0 on the
Left plus 1 on the right so I see how
each of the features influence the the
prediction one way or the other so here
I can see that number of employees for
example influenced a lot to model into
choosing the class 0 whereas other
features like those two here influence
the model in choosing the the class one
so overall
I still predict the class zero but I
know how all although the features
interference in one direction or the
other so that's one thing that you can
start using to debug your model so you
know if you can then talk with a domain
expert and ask like is it is it normal
that this given feature here that has a
real name actually influence my model
into trying to create the class one so
that's the kind of discussion can start
having with with domain experts or like
whoever did that marketing campaign and
then you have the the the same the same
thing but presently does call here in
this in this table you can save that as
I said earlier in a HTML file as well
which is useful to communicate so you
could just do that and then also have it
here somewhere
yeah and just share that with ya so you
can you could just send this file to
someone and share your your results and
as I said in the slides earlier you can
also look a little bit into that linear
regression that your net lime did for
your explanation and see the and see the
the R squared so here we see well you
can see the different weights and you
can see the R squared at a at the bottom
so here we have point 37 so it's not
great but actually at least with all the
explanations of generator with lime so
far it was always fairly low so don't
expect it to be really high it's just
like this but you know how much you can
trust you or your explanation so that's
a that's a nice thing and here I'm going
to do the same thing with all my models
so here let's generate an explanation
for the same observation but looking at
my decision tree instead
and here we are so here R squared is
even lower so the model had the hard
time lime had a hard time trying to
approximate my my model luckily with
only five features yeah it was a with a
linear equation and but I can look at
the are the explanation here so points
76% cos 0 and here we see that all the
features that contributed to this
decision I can do the same for all my
models so that's something that's quite
nice as well it provides that unified
API and you can compare your models and
see how different models pick different
features in your data here they seem to
be all focusing a lot on the number of
employees so I think you should really
get rid of this feature here number of
employees oh he actually looked at the
whether the person was contacted with
the telephone so that's the I wasn't
that one is interesting so finally your
model is doing something right hopefully
so you could report that to the people
doing the campaign saying that well for
this person that's what seemed to have
impacted at least the decision of your
model that you contacted them with
telephone and then where is my extra
boost here it is actually bursts so
really confident that it's going to be
class here and again it's focusing a lot
on the number of employees but then it's
also looking at things like whether the
person was contacted with telephone and
finally it's also looking at
characteristics of the person which is
what you'd like ideally so here
professional training right so that's it
for lime and now the last libraries that
I want to talk about is chef so let's do
that
so what is shop so it's it also
originated from from a paper where part
of the paper is explaining that actually
you that's weird
okay a part of the paper is actually
explaining that generating explanations
for a model consists in can be seen as
as this framework so you have your data
you have a really complex model and that
generates prediction and then in
parallel to that you have an explainer
which is another machine learning model
but simpler to interpret and that's
supposed to approximate your complex
model at least locally and then you
generate explanation from that so just
saying everything that what people did
before to explain models is basically
this framework you're saying my model is
too complex I can't look at it so I'm
building another model that is simpler
and easier to interpret and locally a
good approximation of that model and
that's what you use to generate
explanations then what why does it
disappear okay cool then what they yeah
what they said is that there is a
specific type of explanation it's called
additive feature attribution methods
which lime belongs to this framework as
well which is basically trying to build
a local model that is just a linear
combination of your original features
with whatever value you want here so
lime is doing it by fitting a linear
regression shop is doing it by lip I've
got a weird transitions here shop is
doing it by leveraging Shapley values
from which is a method from game theory
and what it's doing is trying to see how
a feature is impacting is impacting a
decision when it's added to a subset so
it's looking for a given feature say X I
it's going to look at all the subsets of
features that do not have X I in it and
it's looking at it's going to look at
the difference when you're adding X
back to that subset and when it's
averaging all all those impacts of
adding X I to all the possible subsets
of features its able to tell you what
how important X is so it's doing that
for all the features and that's how it's
computing the Phi here so the weight of
different features so I'm just fighting
a little bit with my transitions and
yeah that can be computationally
expensive because you need to look at
all the different subsets of features
that are possible and add everytime X I
and M generate predictions on that and
see how that impacted the prediction so
Schaap is providing different
optimizations that are model-based so
you'll have they have an Ag model
agnostic version as well but they will
have different implementation of the
algorithms for decision trees for
example or tree based models and that's
why we're going to use in in the
notebook so here yet two examples the
the tree explainer that is working for
all tree based models that have a
scikit-learn API so scikit-learn extra
boost like GBM can boost works as well
and then you can explain explain is the
model agnostic one so if none of the
explainers work you can use this one but
it's going to be fairly slow right so
the API
quickly what bits me not sorry it's
quite similar to lime so you first
create your explainer from your model
then you need to compute those shop
value so Shapley values are those that I
was talking about earlier so the impact
of each feature on on your predictions
so they compute all the Shapley values
at once so you need to provide all your
observations and then you will compute a
big matrix of values that contains the
impact of and the importance of each
feature and once you have those values
so that's probably the step step 2 is
probably the one I will take the longest
once you have that you can generate
explanations for given given
well either locally forgiven or given
predictions or globally as well for like
how your model works as a whole all
right so let's do that in do not work so
we import shop here we've got to
initialize JavaScript as well because
it's got a lot of fancy interactivity
things so let's do that we create our
explainer passing our model so here shop
doesn't have a specific way of handling
catechol data so we don't have this
annoying thing to do like we had with
lime then I'm getting my observations
here you see that I actually chose to
only calculate shape values for thousand
dozen samples in my data set because
that can be fairly slow and I just don't
have that much time now so I'm dreaming
of salvations by using my preprocessor
on a thousand random samples in my data
set and then I used I explainer to
compute the Shapley values and I'm
saving it as a matrix that was very
quick I think actually the diversion on
collab seems to do that really well and
really quickly so you can try with the
whole data set if you want worst case is
just the Google cloud instance is going
to freeze or something so that's fine
right so now we can generate some
interesting plots from that so say I
want to look at a specific observation
here so I equals 0 as the first
observation my in my data set so I'm
passing the expected value so that's the
that's the chatelet value 4 that's the
base Shapley value so that if if my
sample didn't lean towards right left
that's what it would be on average so
here that's the base value that
see here and then what's doing instead
is telling me how different different
features influence my decision either on
the right on the on the left on the
right out of this base value so here for
example the number I start from the base
value number of employee employees is
pushing my decisions towards the class
zero so that's been similar to what
we've seen before from lime right so it
has a fairly big impact and you can see
here in pushing my decision towards the
class zero whereas all those features
here seems to be pushing it on the other
side so we've got that feature yet I
don't know what questions to think some
index as well whether the person was
contacted from from a cell phone and
then all the other features here so
that's a nice way to visualize how you
impact and by the way if the shop so
dose this axis here the Shapley value so
if the Shapley value is a negative we're
going to predict 0 if the Shapley values
a positive we're going to predict 1 so
here all those features on the right
hand side here in blue pushing my
decisions negatively so towards the
class 0 and in the end I'm predicting
class 0 so that's nice thing that you
can visualize for a specific observation
but then the power of sharp arrows to do
to visualize those things for all the
features at once so here for example
I've got all all my observations and I
can see how I have that that idea of
pushing the the decision towards the
class 0 class 1 can be seen on the whole
data set so I see oops
you can over here and see that for all
those observations here
the number of employees so that's kind
of starting to give you a global
understanding of your model for all
those observe Asians here the number of
employees seem to be the biggest had
have the biggest impact on a decision
taken by your model and you know so that
it was that the impact was to push it
towards the class zero so not not
subscribed so for all those people here
and then for another another group of of
samples of clients you can see that this
Uwe Boll 3m feature made you made your
model predict the class one so that that
gives you an idea of how your model
works in general with all the samples
that you've provided nice thing that you
can do as well it's look at a feature in
particular so if I want to see how the
number of employees influence my
decisions for all the samples of
provided I see it here and that's I
think really nice right so for for the
number of employees from like four four
thousand nine hundred up to five
thousand I see that in fact is it
affected decision towards the class one
so it pushed it to two one and then it
started to influence it on the other
side when it became bigger so that's
actually like the the first thing you
can start looking at to debug that and
you see that that one that doesn't seem
right
right that that feels like it a that's
that's that notion of proxy I was
talking about earlier here it seems to
be like if if the value is between those
two that range so that's probably a one
given point in time then your campaign
was successful and another point in time
it was not successful so you can like do
all sort of things like that looking at
features in particular the impact of a
for example so I see that for this like
from 20 years old to 60 years old age
doesn't seem to have a big impact on
whether or not the people will will
subscribe whereas up to 60 years old it
has a really big impact in in pushing
into like in pushing decision to the
class 1 which is subscribe so you can
make also of analysis like this on a
like global level which I think it is
really nice and much easier to
communicate and a specific observation
and you can also change the axis here
and I'm going to do this one and well
not the hdn right so you can also see
that the distribution of the number of
employees here so let's just skip that
because much time left
another nice vein shap can do is so that
was so we saw initially local
explanation for one single sample then
we saw a more global one that is showing
a bunch of local observations together
so that's the that's the one we were
doing here and then you also have a
proper global explanation of your model
so it gives you all all the different
aspects so here I can see so if the
value is going to red that means it's
it's higher so higher value of the
number of employees in red here is
affecting my model at a global scale
towards the class zero to more negative
whereas when the number of employees is
in blue so when it's going down it's
affecting my model globally towards the
class one so you can see that for all
the features and that gives you also the
order in which the order of importance
so you start with the number of
employees that's the most important one
globally so that's what we've spotted
already by looking at the
and other other methods and then the
second most important one is this one
same thing the highest it is so when
it's red it's actually pushing your
decisions towards 2 + 0 when it's blue
it's pushing your decision towards the
class 1 and you can see all your
features like this so that's also nice
nice visualization that you can plot and
another one is the dependence plot so
you can see how features you can plot
two features at once and see how they're
together influence the decision so
you've got on the y-axis here the shop
value so if it's positive you're going
to predict arm you're going to predict
one so that the person subscribe
otherwise human to predict the person
didn't subscribe so here the number of
employees you see when number of
employees is higher you tend to do tend
to predict every time that your model is
going that the person is not going to
subscribe
whereas when the number of employees is
lower you tend to predict that the
person is going to subscribe and you can
see how the like another feature here
the contact telephone so whether the
person was contacted by telephone has
changing that as well by looking at
whether the point are red or blue yeah
so that's it for for Shep now I just
wanted to finish that quarter pass right
okay cool so a perfectly good so I just
wanted to show you how you can use lime
for non tabular data so there are plenty
of examples available online for text
data so you can use this tutorials
pretty much out of the box just want to
show you is pictures because I think
it's it's quite nice results let's load
a model pre train from chaos cause I'm
not gonna I'm not that crazy I'm not
gonna train a model now live a deploying
model
so I'm just importing the inception v3
model that is pre trained on image
classification from image net loading it
even loading it is slow actually and
I've got a nice picture of chicken here
so I can load it right and I want to see
if my model is able to predict it so I'm
loading the image in an umpire ray and
I'm generating a prediction so let's see
how good the model is doing we need to
use the decode prediction method so
that's just the prediction will return
label so using the decode prediction
method is provided by Kira's we can know
like the actual class that was predicted
so if you do that all right so my that's
pretty good model predicted 99.9999 that
the that images the token pretty good at
school buses are really really small
probability though so that's that's
pretty good model good job
so now let's let's try to interpret that
so I'm just looking at the different
labels because I need to to pass the
labels of the classes to two line but
then I can load the lime image
explaining here I'm defining my
explainers the same thing as before when
we were using lime on tabular data here
we'll need to pass values arguments to
my explain instance method should I to
pass the actual image as an umpire a I
need to pass my predict function so you
see here it's much easier if we don't
have fancy pre-processing to do because
you can just pass the predict method
from your from your model I just want to
see the top two labels that didn't
matter earlier because we had a binary
classification here we've got so many
classes that we just want to see the two
main classes that predicted number of
samples who actually loaded now because
it's gonna be really slow number samples
so that's the number of samples you
wanna you want a sample from from the
distribution so
earlier I kept the default here I don't
want to because it's fairly slow to
generate images from scratch so here
I've only generated 100 so now we just
import a few helper functions and we're
able to see what what in the model is
picked and know okay you need to import
matplotlib no I did yeah perfect
oh no that's not great okay okay I'm
gonna be crazy and tried doesn't so the
problem is that I did it earlier with a
dozen samples and it the the explanation
was actually pretty good it was looking
at the beak of the of the bird to
predict what the day's gonna be a bird
so it I thought it was pretty good
explanation now it's actually looking at
the background so that's not the right
explanation that I wanted to show oh by
the way there is a bit of that as well
like we are building a new machine
learning model that we are interpreting
so you you might like integrate your own
bias in that model as well so it's not
still not perfect now that's why you
need to discuss with with other people
and domain experts to know whether or
not that interpretation is valid has it
finished okay no it's gonna take a while
is it faster in Inquilab have you guys
run it on in collaborative the dozen
samples he's not working oh really
I don't know okay let's just speed back
a hundred because it's not gonna work is
cool okay so now we could not look at
the explanation oh great
Hey right so that's what I was saying
it's unstable it generated a new
explanation now it's completely
different than the explanation I had
before but this one I'm happy with so
I'm showing it so here it spurted that
the fact that there is this big here and
this color on the bird explains why I
decided it's gonna be a toucan and if I
want to explain only with so here that I
chose five features so an explanation
with five features so it's looking at
five areas in the image that made that
it years to decide on what what class it
will be if I just if I if I just decide
give me one feature only that tells you
to toucan it's looking at this thing
which makes no sense at all but fair
enough and the nice thing that you can
do as well to debug so I guess the
takeaway here is that gotta use more
samples than just a hundred that's not
enough to be to have a an explanation
then is stable the day stable but what
you can do as always this so you can see
what is it saying okay so you can see
how different parts in the image
positively or negatively affected the
outcome oh yeah I'm looking at the bus
okay so I'm looking at so class 779 is
the prediction there was a school bus so
here I'm saying like well take this
prediction it's a school bus and give me
top eight features whether or not it
affected that decision positively or
negatively so here it says that well
that big and that color really doesn't
look much like a school bus but those
parts might do and actually if you would
look at
if she would look into detail in that
part in green here there is a sort of
like something that is bit angular so
that fair enough but that's my
interpretation here so yeah that's
that's it for what the image if want to
delete this one for the image
interpretation and you can do same thing
with with text data as well so that's
that's really nice if you're working
with text data encourage you to look at
at the explainer from line because it
tells you they have an example with
emails and it tells you in an email
what's made it classified as spam or not
spam and so it's actually highlighting
the words so it's quite nice to explain
those decisions right so I can just wrap
it up yes conclusion if you if you're
gonna use complex model you will at some
point I'll need to explain them and and
there are two reasons for that so the
first one can be for ethical or
regulator if we Garrett I have reasons
or the second one is to actually debug
your model so that's why we've seen
earlier like if your model is not
picking the right thing it might be
completely useless in the future when
the data is a little bit different so
you can debug that you can use it to
debug and also you can use it to
communicate to others and that's
probably the most important one that it
empowers you to to to understand better
your model and communicate to others how
decisions were made and then they can
give you feedback on what you need to
change what features you might not want
to include in your model anymore like
we've seen here the number of employees
oh and also in some regulations make it
mandatory so if you're in Europe there
is gdpr so you need to be able to
explain whatever prediction you make
so it's not even your choice anymore if
you want to deploy your model yeah
that's it thank you do we have time for
some questions are we supposed to take
questions
great talk thanks very much I was
wondering where in your workflow usually
model doing model interpretations comes
do you kind of wait until you have a
model that you're happy with to do that
sort of evaluation and or is it every
kind of iteration has some of that
explanation please yeah I think but like
so that's those are the two reasons I
show here there is an even maybe a third
a third one so the first one is using it
to debug your models if you know if it's
doing the right thing so that needs to
be done in your pipeline when you're
trying to fit the best model you need to
know if it's actually doing the right
thing or not then the second one is once
you're happy with the model you need to
communicate it so you need to explain
your decision so that that's second time
when you need to do it and then the
third one is once you deploy it so once
your model is live somewhere there you
need to be able to like rewind and
explain why the decision that specific
decision was made so there would be like
three stages where you need to do it
yeah pretty much that means that that's
I kind of see it as the same way when
you're looking at the accuracy score or
the classification report that that's
the same thing just a little bit longer
other questions
I'm stagnant yep first thanks for
talking demo and also record have
question about lon
can you go back to the page about Lam
using my age to predict which one yeah
this one so you are predicting h20 and
hd60
right and as you can see you are
generating points
locally and what if these two models
have two different intercept it's likely
and how would you explain to people that
okay
you have different intercepts you have
different baseline right that's yeah
that's that that's part of your your
explanation when so like your model is
valid only locally so it never it was
never meant to be globally to explain it
globally so here this model and actually
the intercept you don't even look at it
much you just want to know how how the
feature matters for for your model
locally so here what I'm expecting to do
is this this linear regression is not
it's not building the equivalent of of
my complex model I just want to say in
this locality here how important ages
are like other features and by that I
look at the weight so that you're not
trying to build a good model anyway you
just want to build something that is
good enough approximation locally that
you can say I trust it enough to know
that the age here in this locality is
important or not so you wouldn't you
wouldn't use it to explain your model
globally and even and that's a fair
point ways with the Interceptor that
would be the same for for the different
weights right like at age 20 the age
might not be important at all and then
you would say that is not important
feature and then at age 60 it might
become important and then you would
change completely
you explanation and say well edge is
super important it's it's a local model
only and I say thanks and do you have
any suggestions on how to select our
weights follower question sorry select
the weights
basically the kernel size I mean how
much weight you put on lattice ten
points to compute the similarity of the
data you sample the those weights which
wait are you if so insight is doing a
weighted requestion yeah it's a weights
on requesting so that yet the weights
are computed by Lima I don't know
exactly actually was the I agree I don't
know if you can overwrite it but they
have they're the only way of computing
today it's it's somehow somehow linked
to the distance to the original point
that you want to explain I don't know
exactly what what how to compute it from
there it's just like to to distance and
they have a notion of similarity maybe
you can override it and have your own
you hope your own definition of
similarity there yeah no thanks thank
you thanks for the talk so my question
is demerit when you do the visualization
of of the model using lime and basically
it's just using linear model to
approximate it so I feel like I'm
worried that you know like I tell my
boss that you know I have this black box
motto that kind of works out well and
he's concerned I'm like oh wait but I
have this amazing tool that can
visualize anything but then when I run
it and I but okay it doesn't actually do
a good job kind of approximating the ya
know D'Amato and [ __ ] okay what do I do
like is there anything that can tell me
that can explain why is it not doing
this kind of approximation as good or
how can I improve that what sees the
thing is that you're you're more if
you're gonna use complex models so
but if you like focus on but if you're
using an ensample model or whatever it's
gonna it's not gonna be linear but by
definition so when you're trying to fit
a linear regression there it's it's
never gonna be a perfect fit anyway so
that's you can see how good it was with
the R squared or like debugging a little
bit exactly what what your linear
approximation is but it will never be so
ideally the perfect explanation would be
I if we have a perfect fit locally
that's that's not gonna happen so you
need always to keep that in mind but
it's hard to have like an answer to that
works every time like I guess it
depended that's probably one of the
issues as well with those methods is
that you're building a new model it's
simpler and then you you're interpreting
that yourself so there's a lot of bias
going on there so here so I don't really
have an answer to this question yeah I
wish I knew but you only you're building
a new model that is an approximation
that isn't perfect and you're trying to
use that as a proxy to understand the
impact of your features that's all
you're doing and then yeah you can say
whether or not that that makes sense and
you can also check whether or not that
approximation is good that's all
you can do pretty much I'm not sure I'm
so you could say yeah that's fair enough
Thanks that make sense
wondering if there's like maybe maybe
this is just a question bout the paper
but are there bounds on like the
confidence of these linear
approximations to your model is it easy
to bound it so that you could at least
say like oh this approximates with the
original model with this confidence I
know that we have R squared to say how
well it's doing in that region but
within in terms of like relating it to
the original model
you mean globally even on local patches
yeah because you know on you that most
will really be taken only locally first
thing right it has no sense at all
globally but then yeah locally you can
only do you can only see how the
linearity how good an approximation your
linear regression is yeah there isn't
much more that you can do then that you
can run it's several times actually that
would be a good idea because you're
still sampling you had there is the
instability due to the random sampling
so it's it's really not a perfect
technique there should be some way to
bound the error though like in relation
to the original model anyway all over
the paper yeah okay well my actual
question is Stan or the what was the the
last visualization you showed I free the
name of schaap ship yeah so can you talk
about the units on the other on this
axis yes and also oh yeah good so those
are the the shop values so that they
don't i think the unit less okay these
are some comet oriole yeah it's just I
was explaining really quickly right here
so we're just like trying to measure the
impact of adding each feature to all the
subsets of features that don't have this
and then we aggregate that somehow and
that's how we get this this value
whether it positively or negatively
affects it so
can you get this this Shapley value that
you can compare from a feature to
another okay but by itself I don't think
you can tell much with the value you can
only compare it with the rest I've gotta
make sense so when you have it here
here at the point the minus point to two
point one itself doesn't tell you much
but then you can compare by how how much
of an impact so it's just a measure of
impact so the the number of employees
here seems to be to have a larger
amplitude in making in pushing it to the
negative side whereas this feature here
has a different amplitude so it's it's
used to compare the the importance of
the different features but by itself
doesn't have much meaning okay
[Applause]